u.s. pressure on China is rising Senator
Graham a longtime opponent of Beijing
has put forward the kovat 19
accountability act this is a law that if
passed would give Donald Trump the
ability to put new sanctions on China
I'm convinced that without Chinese
Communist Party deception the virus
would not be here in the United States
China refuses to allow the international
community to go into the Wuhan lab to
investigate they refused to allow
investigators to study how this outbreak
started this hard-hitting piece of
legislation will sanction China until
they cooperate with investigators China
immediately spoke up decrying the bill
the bill introduced by several US
senators absolutely neglects facts they
want to start the investigation with the
presumption of guilt to shift their
responsibility on China for the failure
and incompetence in the fight against
the epidemic this is not possible who
expressed a resolute protest in my
openings I think some senator of the
United States sometimes like a paper
tiger and and they just pretended to be
a piper and make Chinese a scare in fact
some of them they don't need here to
choose from the China so I think that
the scene is very very obvious there is
nowadays in America there are over
80,000 people time and in the future
there will be more so this is a Jesus
news they failed to protect their people
and they you want to share the
responsibilities so that's why they just
want to make China to be the scapegoat
and I think this is their critical
target Australia seems to be echoing the
anti China chorus coming from the United
States down under there are lots of
calls for a probe into China so far the
United States has only gotten warnings
of retribution from Beijing but
Australia has already started to feel
China's wrath
China has suspended beef imports from
Australia Plus China is now threatening
an 80 percent tariff on Australian bar
imports both sides deny that the
tensions are a factor in these dramatic
trade moves google hagwons at the
chinese customs found that multiple
batches of beef products exported to
China by certain Australian companies
violated the Inspection and Quarantine
agreed by Chinese and Australian
authorities in order to protect the
health and safety of Chinese consumers
China has decided to suspend taking
import declarations for meat products
from four Australian companies I think
we have to be careful not to draw lines
between these two things it's an anti
dumping issue from the Chinese
perspective they certainly haven't
raised it as connected to any other
issues not the extremely disappointed if
it was there's no reason for me to think
based on the way that they're
approaching that I could draw that
conclusion the media has been quick to
recall recent remarks from a Chinese
official I think in the long term if the
mood is going from bad to worse maybe
ordinary people will say why should we
drink Australian wine or eat Australian
beef connection or not China is
Australia's largest export market jobs
and livelihoods are on the line
Australia is calling for trade talks as
well as an investigation into the
origins of the corona virus the media
now accuses China of waging a trade war
amid the pandemic now Australian beef
may simply not be up to Chinese
standards however many interpret this as
China reminding the world that it does
not take accusations and sanctions
lightly and it's capable of striking
back if China didn't stop the conflict I
think the world will become worse and
worse so that's a why China tipped
restraint the Australia is different
Australia China relationship used to be
very very good it's very disappointed
for Chinese people cause Australia push
to promote United States policy so
that's why nowadays we just have to do
something to response
you